So, first exercise—anybody been to Panera before?
I love Panera. I’ve got these little kids,
they can make a mess and it's kind of
acceptable. We try to clean up, but—
So Panera, one of the main focuses of their
menu is that you pick two. So that's what
we're going to do. You get to pick two. There’s
a bunch of cards in the center of your table,
and in a minute what I'm going
to ask you to do is pick two.
You can spread out the deck so you can actually
look and shop for the words. Pick two words that,
if combined well, could transform your year.
So pick two words that—if combined—and the
combination is important. Because if you
just get soup, you miss out on the salad.
And so by picking two words—sometimes
chocolate is good and sometimes peanut
butter is good—but you give me a Reese's
and I'm like, "Yes, give me more of that."
All right. So pick two words
that you feel like, if combined,
could transform the rest of your year.
Pick them, and then once you've got them,
share it with just one other person
right next to you. All right—go for it.
Once you’ve got two, you don’t have to wait for
me. I know, I know—we're all suited up. I have to
say, you all look sharper than the CIA. I’ve done
a series of sessions with the CIA, and I’m looking
at you—you’re taking a group picture out there—and
I'm like, “Dang, you’re not looking serious.”
So just because we have jackets on right
now, really inviting levity—there’s not
like... you're not going to break rules,
you're not going to screw up video footage,
anything like that. So in other words,
you don't need to wait for all my cues.
So feel free—if you got two cards, just with
the one other person, because you're kind of
splitting your table in half—share your
thought process behind that combination.
All right—what are you gonna do
tomorrow? Hey, very good. Exactly.
So, depending on how I’m feeling,
sometimes I’ll get on an airplane
and when somebody turns to me and asks
me, "Hey, what do you do?" First of all,
I’m like, “You don't even know
what landmine you just stepped on.”
But depending on how I’m feeling, I’ll say,
“Well, half my job is starting conversations
and the other half is ending them.”
I don’t really say that too often,
but I'm glad you appreciated that.
So I'm saying that to you now.
Just because we're filming lots of different
exercises, if we had more relaxed time,
I probably wouldn't interrupt quite
as quickly. But for the sake of time,
I'm going to be stopping a lot of
conversations—perhaps before their time is due.
And let that just be an invitation to
continue it over lunch, during breaks,
the rest of the time that you spend with
each other. The idea here is really that
the conversations we start here become little
anchors and seeds to start future conversations.
What happens is, when we have dialogues
and connections like this with people—when
you pass someone in the hallway, or
you see a client at a grocery store,
or whatever else—if you have some of this personal
information, some knowledge of who they are,
it's much more easy, and you're much more
likely to stop and say, “Hey, how is the blank?”
Right? In your roles, you get all up in somebody's
life, and so you have a lot of those details.